ça c'est la vraie tragédie du FN
l'élection qui leur réussit le mieux
c'est celle où ils sont obligés d'aller
travailler à l'étranger
et j'accueille maintenant Gaspard Proust
pour la vie
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce qui se passe
il est il est parti Moscou vissy venez
Vichy là
c'est con parce que c'était le seul
intime sur le plateau c'est le seul mec
qui connaît le montant de mes impôts
donc
en plus moi je voulais lui dire merci
pour cette très belle réforme fiscale
dans l'égalité juste de la justice
égalitaire pour tous c'est vraiment au
début je pensais qu'il y en avait que
pour nous les riches tu vois toi moi
Tellier Deutsch mais non c'est vraiment
une réforme de cohésion sociale depuis
que les pauvres sont imposés j'ai enfin
trouvé un sujet de discussion avec eux
[Applaudissements]
non mais vraiment grâce à Moscovici un
riche peut enfin se plaindre des impôts
avec impôts c'est maintenant moi je vais
au supermarché tu vois je vois je vois
retraité comme ça qui se plaint oh là là
c'est la première année que je dois
payer des impôts et moi je fais ah ouais
c'est vrai c'est dur et puis il me dit
oui en plus je vais pas arriver à payer
l'EDF moi je fais semblant de comprendre
ce que c'est que l'EDF parce que tu vois
j'ai un comptable qui fait ça je suis
pas au courant ça doit être une niche
fiscale je sais pas votre truc
je me demandais il y a eu des réformes
des retraites là il y a eu la création
d'un compte pénibilité est-ce que ça va
concerner les malheureux qui doivent
commenter une actualité qui n'a aucun
intérêt non parce que pour nous la les
mineurs du PAF c'est dur là c'est pas
tous les jours le 11 septembre moi là je
non mais j'ai un travail très pénible
figurez-vous que pour faire cette
chronique je suis parfois obligé de lire
Marianne ou Libé non
[Musique]
Marianne c'est un peu comme écouter
d'usage quoi tu vois au bout de trois
mesures tu as envie de tondre un peu
caché
bref
[Applaudissements]
jour de France jour en France ça bouge à
Brignoles ça y est ils l'ont fait le
lancement des travaux du futur centre
aquatique intercommunal c'est
parce que le FN triomphe à Brignoles
dans le Var c'est normal c'est les gens
ils s'attendaient à quoi au Front de
Gauche enfin Brignoles c'est quand même
plus mirador les pins que goulag les
Mimosas
les électeurs du FN inexpriment pas leur
album il décompresse
vos TFN dans le Var c'est du Feng Shui
c'est
comme manger 5 fruits et légumes par
jour c'est un réflexe naturel c'est
c'est une vidange quoi de toute façon la
montée du FN je m'en je m'en fous
totalement ça me met alors non parce que
concrètement ils vont ils vont changer
quoi à Brignoles qu'est-ce qu'ils vont
changer on fera un rond-point en forme
de plastique
frapper une monnaie locale après
l'urofort le brignemou
et puis la préférence nationale ils vont
l'appliquer à qui au type qui viennent
d'Aubagne de Nice enfin tu vois c'est
pas
alors tout le monde dit qu'ils feront un
score très important aux européennes ça
c'est la vraie tragédie du FN l'élection
qui leur réussit le mieux c'est celle où
ils sont obligés d'aller travailler à
l'étranger
très
il ne faut pas se voiler la face non
parce que l'immigration c'est un
problème en ce moment c'est vrai que
c'est l'invasion il y a trop d'espagnol
Vals à l'intérieur Lopez à Brignoles en
ce moment je serai flic je vérifierai
les papiers de Luis Fernandez
très très polémique très très vaste bien
pas bien tout ça il est peut-être pas à
sa place c'est vrai qu'on a jamais vu un
ministre de l'Intérieur qui s'occupe
autant de l'exportation
et qu'il fait assez mal en terme de
livraison DHL envoyer un rhum au Kosovo
parce qu'il y a ce cas très polémique en
ce moment c'est la fille elle se fait
choper lors d'une sortie scolaire alors
ils allaient visiter une usine Peugeot à
Sochaux moi je comprends qu'on les
retiré avant l'arrivée à destination
[Applaudissements]
quand tu accueilles un étranger chez toi
en vacances tu la mets le voir
Versailles la Tour Eiffel pas aller au
fourneau de Florange tu vois
exécutif le président baisse encore oui
c'est possible
il a beau être contre les gaz de schiste
et la fracturation hydraulique au niveau
popularité il a inventé la fracturation
son d'agir
il existe le trou noir de l'Ifop c'est
le héros baisse aussi mais moi après par
rapport à héros la vraie question c'est
est-ce que les gens qui ont été sondés
savent vraiment qui ont leur a parlé
bon sport alors vous avez vu cette série
de victoires de l'équipe de France ils
ont battu la Biélorussie 4 à 2
l'Australie 6 à 0 la Finlande 3-0 c'est
révélateur
tu comprends qu'ils vont mal quand on
arrive plus à battre d'efforts on
humilie les faibles
c'est vrai que les adversaires de la
France ne sont pas terribles en ce
moment mais bon faut pas oublier
qu'avant de pénétrer la Russie
l'Allemagne s'est chauffé en Pologne
quoi non historiquement c'est injuste
après ils ont fait un sondage chez nos
chers compatriotes les joueurs de
l'équipe de France seraient trop payé
individualiste et grossier excusez-les
d'avoir réussi
parce que 82 % des Français ont une
mauvaise opinion des joueurs de foot
c'est inquiétant c'est à dire que 82%
des français ont une opinion sur le foot
c'est ça qui est vraiment le
amour un père était condamné une amende
de 500 euros pour avoir remis une fessée
déculottée à son fils 500 euros alors on
dit que le gamin avait les fesses toute
rouge heureusement pour le Père tu vois
s'il l'avait mise moins forte il était
condamné pour pédophilie
je suis désolé 500 euros si même la
violence conjugale devient un sport de
riche
alors peut-être terminé par une bonne
nouvelle parce que oui bien sûr
évidemment on ira un père pourra épouser
sa fille adoptive voilà après Paris
Barcelone et Rome on connaît le prochain
endroit où on va tourner Audi Allen ah
alors
[Applaudissements]
dis-tu abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce
bleu